[Music] Hi, I'm Rich. I work at Posit,
formerly RStudio, and I work on the gt package,
have been working on it for a while,
and we have a great new release 0.8,
and today I'd like to show you what we improved
in terms of, like, new functions in the package,
and also what we improved in terms of existing
functions in the package. We added a bunch of
great new functions to target values and do cool
things like replace the values of the things that
were targeted or style the cells, and the other
thing is improvements to date and time formatting
especially. So, I'm really excited to talk
about these new features. Let's dive right in.
So, the first function I want to talk about
is sub underscore values or sub values,
so it's essentially like a find and replace. So,
we have a table here, I just made that with the
table function from dplyr. I'm showing you the
table now in the console and we could look at
the table as it is in gt just by piping it to the
gt function, so this is the table just down here.
Format is HTML. So we can use sub values. I'm
using it three times here but I'll show you each
time I use it that we can find and replace values.
So, in the first case I'm taking, I'm looking,
for values like 74 or 500 and replacing with 150.
So if I run this, this is going to change very
subtly, but you'll see 150 is there now. Okay, if
you do the same thing with finding the letter 'b'
and replacing with the word 'be' that works. It'll
just skip over these numeric columns and go right
to the thing that is the character column. And
same thing with 800. You can replace any text,
so it could be like any size text, replacing the
value '800' with the words 'eight hundred' right
here. So, that's the values, you do quite a bit
with it. You can even have, like, patterns. If
you know about regex you'll know what this is,
essentially it could be 'A' or 'C' or 'E'. If
you find any of those you're going to replace
the whole cell with 'ace'. So, let's run this.
You can see right here that these values right
here are replaced with that replacement value.
Sweet, so we can do more advanced things -
use a function that you supply for instance,
so this would be like values that are less
than 50, and the text you're going to replace
those values with is 'Under 50'. So, let's
just run this and take a look at the result.
There we are, lots of values which are 'Under 50'
in this column and also in the first column. It
totally ignores the column that which doesn't have
numerical values at all, which is kind of nice.
You don't have to specify which columns, it won't
error on you or do weird things. So, that's the
values. I'm going to talk about another function
which is new in gt 0.8. It is tab_style_body().
Okay, so let's start with a initial table right
here. This is just like an example table, I mean
that I use a lot in gt for examples, and what we
can do now is we could do a similar sort of thing.
We can find values and then style the cells that
have those values, so these are literal values
49.95 and 3333. They exist over here, so let's
actually run this and see what the result is.
Okay, so we got some values which are colored
orange. That's because we have the style here
set with this helper function called cell
underscore fill, and the color of orange,
so we're essentially filling those
targeted cells with that styling.
So, we could do lots more with this. We could have
multiple styles. You just enclose them in a list.
We can style the text. We could style the fill of
the cells that we target. We can even style the
borders of those, so we're doing the same thing
targeting the same values. So, if I run this
you'll see that the only thing that changes is in
those two cells. The styling will totally change.
There we go. So, it's totally different styling
by targeting the same cells with these literal
values. So that's tab_style_body. There's more
to it. It's kind of like sub values that I
spoke about earlier, and you can have different
types of targets. You can target row and target
column. What's that do? It just means that if
it finds anything like a cell it'll just, like,
style the entire row or the entire column. So,
let's actually take a look at that. So, let's
do the this whole statement. Run it. And you see
here that because it found 49.95 over here, and we
said targets equals row, it's going to style it
with cell fill color of light green all the way
across. So, it's a good way of highlighting a row
just based on, just based on the data you have,
if you want to highlight a row. You can do the
same thing with, with this statement right here,
column, so it found this value. It's a little
hard to read but that's 33.33, because we have
targets equals columns, we're styling the
entire column. So, that's what that does.
I'm going to skip ahead here, and move to another
new function we have in gt 0.8. It's extract cells
so, what it is, it allows you to pull out certain
cells from a gt table so you have a gt table, but
you just want like a value from that table, and
you want to put it somewhere. You can do that with
this function here. So, it's actually best shown
in a Quarto document. I have one open right here.
So, what I'm doing is I'm making a giant
table here, and the key to this is I have
a table. I saved it as such, like I assigned it
to this object and displaying it, but I have it
assigned as an object. That's a key thing here.
So, what you can do in Quarto, and in R Markdown,
is you can use inline R code. It's basically this
backtick with an r and some code inside there,
and closing with the backtick. So that's kind of
cool, because we can actually take that gt table,
pipe it into extract cells, pull out the cell we
want. And the interesting thing about this is that
cell is already fully formatted, so you'll get
the same formatting in the text of your document.
It's a little hard to imagine that right now,
because we just have this source document. So,
let's actually render it. I'm going to hit
the render button and then it's going to do
its thing in that background jobs window, and
when it's done, it should appear as a preview.
And the key thing is we'll see in this last
paragraph that we'll have a value from the table.
Okay great, so I'm going to expand this a little
bit. Move to the bottom, so I kept the code in
here. The table should be below. Great, so I pull
out a value which is one of these fractions. It's
a little bit hard to format in HTML. You have to
do, you know, a little bit of, like, tag stuff,
but we don't have to worry about that because
we have extract cells, and we pulled out the
cell which is from column F underscore sold and
row number 14. And it's right here, 2 over 10.
And that's basically this one over here. So kind
of nice you didn't have to replicate that. You
can use something you already have inside your
document, and it saves a lot of transcription
problems in the future. And is, you know, if
this table changes, this changes accordingly,
which is really cool. So, that's extract cells.
We have another new function in gt 0.8, and it is
the one called cols_align_decimal. So, this is
like an often requested bit of functionality. So,
we have a table here for instance.
Let's see here. Let's run this,
so we're just generating a table. It's a really
simple table, just for demonstration purposes,
and say we want to format this entire column
of numbers. If we want three decimal places,
we want drop any trailing zeros, and that's, you
know, that's pretty much it for that column. So,
let's actually run that little bit right
there. Okay, this is great. The problem
is that it's a little hard to read, because
the decimals aren't lined up in a way that,
you know, makes it easy to say, see what is,
you know, before and after the decimal mark.
And there's not always a decimal mark here.
This is like a whole number with no decimal.
It's a little hard to read, you know, it's
not impossible, but it's not, you know,
it could be better. So, that's where this function
comes in. cols_align_decimal, you just run that.
You can target a column, but you don't have
to. It just runs across the entire table,
looks for columns that have numbers formatted. It
just does the thing. So, let's actually run this.
Great okay, so an immediate improvement.
So, basically, what we have now is,
we have the decimal running all the way down. I
mean this is like a sort of extreme example. We
have NA's and sort of some wild values here, but
the idea is that it's a little easier to read,
especially if you, you know, just have a ton of
these values. You just want to see what the big
part is and what the small part of the number
is. So, that's cols_align_decimal, just decimal
alignment. So, next is information about your
table. You might make a really complex table
like this, you know. If you're a beginner with
gt, you may not know what this is. That's fine,
that's actually, that's actually just fine.
So, let's run this. Let's show the table.
So, it's a pretty nice looking table.
We have, you know, row labels here,
and we have column labels across the top,
and a spanner that spans across two columns,
and some formatted values in the body. So, that's
great, you might get this table, or you might want
to style something like, say for instance, you
know this column, or some cell in there. Right, so
we don't know how to do that, because what you
need to do is, you have to know the ID value
of, you know, like the column and also of
the row. So, to help that, we have this new
function called tab underscore info or tab info
for short. You just pass that your gt table,
and what you get is an information table that
shows you what your columns are called in terms
of IDs, and then what the labels are. So, you
can sort of see what you have currently in your,
in your, viewer, in terms of what you have in
your table, and you make the correspondence
between that and your actual, like, ID, which is
used for styling and for things like footnotes.
So, we have that, even the rows
might be labeled differently than
their ID values, and it also works for spanners
as well, so whatever you have in your table,
this will reveal what the ID values are.
And this is important because sometimes
with certain functions in gt, it just creates IDs
for you, and you have no idea what they are. So
this gives them to you, so you can do styling.
So, if you go back to your other table here,
we want to style say, for instance, this column
right here, and you know we didn't know what this
was called. For instance, we know it's actually
mpgt, mpg underscore c, from this table here,
right here. That's what it appears to be, and
that's what it is. So, now if we run this,
we can successfully style that entire column
with a background color of light blue,
because if you just put an MPG like
this, we would just get an error.
The next function I want to talk about,
actually, it's a set of functions,
that have to do with the date and time formatting
features in gt. We have a number of functions,
format date format time, format date time,
those are going to, completely been overhauled,
rewritten. Totally feature-packed now, lots more
power than before, and we hope it's actually even
easier to use than before. So, let's get right
to it. So, let's start with a date time string.
So, we can actually format that with this
other function. It's a variant of format date,
vec_format_date, so it's great for examples,
and it's great for anything inside,
you know, R Markdown or Quarto, if you just
need formatted values like from vectors,
and not from columns of values in a table. It's
also good for demonstration purposes. So, it has
all the same features. It just works on vectors
rather than columns in a table. So, if we were to
take our date string, what we can do is, we could
use a date style, and these are name styles that
are available in this function. And also in this
function, it just allows easy access to, like,
styling, you know, an input date time, to whatever
output date time. So, we do the same thing for,
for many times. So, we're just getting the time
portion of this out. In this case we're getting
10:05 PM because that's what that is here in the
string, so it's, it's all very overwhelming. Like,
where do we get these, you know, there's lots of
them. We actually have a function in gt, called
info_date_style. We can just run that, and what it
does is it gives us a table of all the different
format names that you can use here in date style,
and it gives you an example with an input. And,
so you can just look down, and see what, you
know, the different outputs are for the same date,
so really kind of cool. You just gotta copy
and paste this, put into here, and you're off
essentially. So, same sort of thing for the time
styles, because it's a separate function. It's
got a separate function for the input table right
here. Great, so you see hmp is this right here,
and this is the example format of time, so that's
all great. We also have this other function
called format_date_time. It has tons of power. It
allows you to actually use a formatting string,
and to, you know, style your dates, date
time strings just the way you want them.
So, we can use date_styles, and we can
use time_styles together, and it'll
separately format those two parts and give you
an output. So, let's actually see it in practice.
So, we get this. We get the date, and then we get
the time, just after that. Okay, a cool new thing
that was added in the latest release is that you
can have locales. So, say for instance you are,
you, want a time in a different language. So,
you can use the same input. You just have to
use locale, and then the name of the locale, and
you will get the output date in that language,
like basically specific for that locale. So,
that's a new thing. So, another new thing is we
have a totally different way of formatting dates
and times with this new type of format string.
You can still use the old type, that hasn't
changed, but it will detect whether using this
other type, which is called cldr. So, it basically
has more fields for, for, my dates and times. It's
way more flexible. It has tons of support for time
zones as well, if you have that in your input,
which is totally supported here. But, I just want
to say that this is a great way of formatting
really advanced dates and times. So that's one
example here, and it's fully localizable, so we
can just put the locale here, and it just switches
it to, like, the Dutch version of that date time,
which is really cool. So, learning about
this is actually kind of difficult it's like,
I don't see, like, you need a crash course in
this whole thing, but it's no problem, because
we actually have documentation and it's really
extensive in the, in the project website for gt,
and that's available at gt.rstudio.com, and
particularly look at the reference section,
and you'll find that the date time formatting
functions and the documentation is super huge,
and there's tons of help on all this
stuff. So, that's all I have for the
new enhancements and features in gt. This is
a great script it allows you to sort of, like,
test out things that are new, and we'll have
this script available for everybody to use,
and the link to it will be available in the
video notes. If you have any questions about gt,
you can always ask me in the issues in gt, which
is at the GitHub repository for the package. If
you want to have a reference for gt, you can go
to gt.rstudio.com. There's a full reference there,
lots of articles and lots of reference materials
for you to learn how to use the package.[Music]